let's go back to the phones and by
phones I mean Discord we're using
digital phones at this point
davidpackman.com Discord is the place to
go let's go to Thai from Connecticut Ty
what is going on
uh hey David
um I just wanted to
kind of give my uh the two cents on like
I think it was a re-upload you did
um
about Obama the comments that he had
about like the too far left in the work
left and this and that and
I just I really
I really struggled with that one because
in my opinion I think uh Obama is
probably more
um
responsibility I'm still here yeah it's
probably more responsible for I think
I think the disillusionment of a lot of
activists and maybe the rise of evokism
uh then
um
I mean any other phenomena I can think
of certainly that was how I was
effective being disappointed by
um
the lack of
um
Progressive uh ideals and policy I mean
this whole Avenue was written in by
Citigroup you know he bailed out
Banks and not the homeowners he
continued torture he I think I think
more than anything of any single policy
issue that really drives me insane is
that I think that he is somewhat
responsible for
the rise of trump
I'm I think that here's the here's why I
struggle with let's just pick one thing
because you're mentioning you're
mentioning a lot and I don't know if a
question is coming so let me just
comment on one aspect of that it's not
really it's not really a question it's
not it's just me being displeased yeah
so listen I mean here's the thing the
entire like Obama led to Trump sort of
thing the reason I find that to be
really tough is one perspective is Obama
led to Trump by not being as Progressive
as he pretended he was going to be which
disillusioned people which caused some
people to say I'm not going out to vote
for Hillary so let it be Trump if that's
the alternate okay so like that's one
perspective the other perspective is
Obama by being half black allowed Trump
to coalesce nativists xenophobes
starting with the birth certificate
thing moving into the Mexican rapist
thing and so like that's a different way
in which you could say Obama led to
Trump but it's just Obama's identity
it's nothing he can control so I don't
know I think there's a mix of stuff that
went on can I just add one little quick
thing to that very last point because I
wanted to touch on that yeah sure is
that I find him
responsible for a lot of that because in
in the face of that that
virulent gross racism that was
festering and targeted at him I mean the
reason why Donald Trump even became a
popular political figure in this modern
era was because he was on Fox News every
other month talking about how Obama was
wasn't a you know American because he
was black and and here's my frustration
with kind of like where you're going
with Obama saying is that was the moment
we needed the wokism that was the moment
that we needed him to call that a spade
for a spade and not play around with it
and joke with it like it was something
funny and to bring attention to it and
to have the political historical uh
foresight and uh retrospective to
understand what it is that you're
placating instead of having beer Summits
with police who murder innocent black
people and yeah I don't I don't I think
I get where you're going I don't know
that my view on it is so black and white
I think you can have the beer Summit to
send one signal and then you can take
seriously the birth certificate thing
and then you can joke about it at the
White House correspondence dinner I
don't know to say those are the reason
that that I I struggle with that but let
me give it some more thought I'm glad
you've had your opportunity to uh to to
make your point and I hope to hear from
you again
okay thank you take care and just as a
reminder please get right to your
question because we do have a lot of
people that want to get on and I think
as a general thing people will be
um appreciative of that uh and that's an
important thing let's go to Steve from
the San Francisco Bay Area Steve welcome
to the program what's on your mind today
hey Dave cool to talk to you again thank
you
um
I I agree with Jill about the uh fjb
stickers on the Christian cars like I'm
a Christian you know that and that's
just not cool anyways on my question yep
um so I was talking to a co-worker the
other day about like how much money
would it take for you to just quit your
job retire and just pursue whatever you
wanted to pursue and not have to like
work for money
um like my my number would be like five
to ten million I guess but that's
arbitrary it's in for each person what
would uh you don't have to share what
your number would be but what would you
do if like money wasn't a factor for you
would you continue doing this show would
you do something else yeah I'm doing it
now I mean that's the amazing I'm doing
what I want to be doing and it's great
that it's worked out to be you know a
business that functions but I'm I'm
doing the thing I want to be doing
that's great yeah and it's not just
money that's pretty sweet I mean I guess
maybe I'd consider going and like
selling athletic shoes or something like
that but I kind of like what I'm doing
cool what do you do in your free time
for hobby hobbies and like just personal
growth this is quite a call I I read I
travel I go to the gym I bike and run
you know I hang out with my baby
daughter which takes up a lot of time a
lot a lot of time if you want to if you
want to figure out uh you know how to
really optimize your time have a have a
baby around
um what else what are my other Hobbies I
don't know making prank phone calls to
other political shows oh damn I'm not
supposed to say that
um no I don't know I mean you know it's
all it's all pretty basic
cool yeah I just wanted to ask an
atypical question more about your
personal uh opinions on some
non-political things so that's all but
that thanks for taking my call what show
are you watching right now
I'm not watching anything I'm just
waiting in the lobby getting ready to go
to work no I don't mean literally right
now I'm just saying is there a TV show
right now that you're watching oh I'm
sorry
uh ah man a show I'm I mean I
there's a lot out there I'm I really was
in the rings of power while that was on
and I binged the crap out of that
haven't heard of that all right all
right well thank you for the call I
appreciate it oh thanks man all right
there we go I'll have to check I'll have
to check out that show it sounds sounds
compelling to some degree
good habits have to be sustainable in
order to become habits it has to be
something you'll actually do and when it
comes to nutrition some people have
hours to plan out every meal their exact
vitamin intake I'm not doing any of that
I don't have the time here's what's
sustainable for me I start my day with
just a single scoop of ag-1 from
athletic greens it gives me the entire
day's worth of the 75 high quality
vitamins minerals and probiotics I want
from whole food sources it's just simple
it's just one scoop of ag1 I get all the
nutrients I want I don't have to do any
math use my protractor my TI-83 or take
a bunch of different capsules and pills
it's not some kind of wacky supplement
making a bunch of crazy claims you know
I would not promote something like that
ag1 is just a simple product it does
what it says it does it gives you the
daily nutrients and vitamins you likely
want vitamin A C E magnesium zinc
potassium in one simple scoop you keep
your body nourished you'll also get a
free year supply of vitamin D which I
take in the winter plus five free travel
packs at athleticgreens.com Pacman the
link is down below